oh I should stop what are you gonna do  now huh exhibit a Oakland resident  Justin Pinsky posted on message board  Romania has a storied history of  executing their leaders couldn't they do  us a solid and take out bush now this  looks juicy fishery Cheech at and this  is Jack and this is Mark Oh lovely  you're our second same-sex couple today  attempt narration take one I'll take two  three when James was four years old his  older sister disappeared while making a  documentary near the town of  Burkittsville Maryland the final moments  and that showed her going into a house  seemingly within the Black Hills for us  Sully  don't worry he did a great thing  it's gonna be remembered for a very long  time it's a funny thing I've delivered a  million passengers over 40 years in the  air but in the end I'm gonna be judged  on 208 seconds  look tomorrow's gonna be a good day  computer sends will prove you a race